chapter 283 of my hero academia is a
historic point for the series
it gave us a moment that will be
remembered for years to come and will
probably break the internet when it gets
animated
also not to brag or anything but i
totally predicted this in my q a video
which i uploaded yesterday so if you
want to check that out the link will
also be on screen and in the description
the full official chapter will be out on
the weekend which will have way more
details than this video here
so this is just a broad overview of what
happens for those of you who are
interested and impatient like i am
this chapter is titled 75 which is a
reference to the fact that shiguraki was
rudely awoken by the heroes
when he was at 75 completion so his body
isn't 100
ready yet and until now we've not really
seen any
repercussions of that however before we
can get back to shigaraki
the chapter actually begins back at the
forest with jiro momo
and a bunch of other students from
classes one a and b
looking on in horror at the destruction
that gigantomachia is causing
within the rubble we see tokyomi
carrying a gravely wounded hawks
and apparently he's also carrying
someone else with dark shadow though
the leaks don't specify who this is momo
looks on
and says oh my god as she starts to
contemplate how they ever thought they
were safe
as machia just continues his rampage one
of the students uses their quirks to
float everyone in the air
and therefore avoid maki's destruction
and this is most likely the uh the
poltergeist guild from class 1b
moneta asks the very deep question of
whether the hero's actions were correct
whether they did the right thing
and the following panel then focuses on
an unconscious hawks
this moment is designed for us to
consider whether hawks did the right
thing
in murdering twice and i gotta say my
personal opinion is that
yes he did because it's an undeniable
fact that if twice was to live
that would only cause more death and
more suffering for both innocent people
and the heroes we then see gigantomachia
tearing through the city which he was
towering over
at the end of chapter 282 and believe me
the destruction is even worse than what
you're imagining right now
i don't think hero society can ever be
the same after this moment
like this is 10 times worse than kamino
we see people on the ground running away
but it's totally pointless
as chunks of buildings and cars just
come hurtling towards them
machia roars loudly and according to the
spoilers he thinks to himself
that he feels like he's coming to life
if that translation is accurate then oh
boy
all we know is that whatever that
sedative was it activates the more
machia moves around momo said it herself
so you know he's moving around quite a
bit right now he's destroying entire
cities
and yet instead of feeling sleepy he
feels like he's coming to life
what does that mean what was this stuff
i will admit that momo's internal
dialogue it always seems to indicate
that she's on the side of the heroes
you know she never thinks any villainous
thoughts or anything like that
but it's just getting very suspicious
now we need answers
we need answers at this moment the
league of villains are still just
chilling on makia's back
as dabi smiles happily at all the
destruction they're now super close to
shigaraki
and we know this because dr garaki is
able to hear machias raw
and said that makio was engineered to
die for his master
in his words the nomu are simply
imitations of gigantomachia
and his willingness to do anything for
sugaraki the scene then pans to the
nearly higher nomus
still fighting many of the heroes which
is something we hadn't seen for many
many chapters and i was starting to
wonder
if they'd been defeated or something but
no they are still fighting the heroes
the manga then switches to the main
battlefield where shoto had just arrived
in the last chapter
he uses his eyes to slide past endeavour
and apologizes for being late to help
telling his father that he can now you
know take some time to cool down
and avoid overheating in previous
chapters we saw how endeavour used the
vanishing fist
as well as a bunch of other attacks on
shiguraki and yeah by this point he was
getting a lot
lot weaker even gran torino said it so
he does need to take a break of some
kind
meanwhile deku bravely blasts off
straight towards shigaraki
as both bakago and roklot shout out that
this is a terrible idea
telling him to get away midoriya's face
is filled with rage
as tears are just streaming down his
cheeks and he replies to rock clocks
saying that he doesn't want to run away
i honestly cannot believe there are
people out there who just disrespect
deku like
how can you tell me this guy isn't one
of the most fearless main characters
around
ashigaraki goes to say something he's
unable to complete his sentence because
a massive gash just appears on the right
side of his body
with blood squirting out from both his
chest and his shoulder
just looking at this panel myself it'll
almost look like his right arm is about
to fall off
shiggy yells out in horror as he looks
down at his own body
saying to himself that he understands
his body wasn't yet complete
and that he's been moving above his
physical limitations
deku thinks to himself that shiguraki's
hyper regeneration
is probably about to start working and
ponders the fact that you know
he also has multiple quirks inside one
for all he considers that gran torino
doesn't have much time left to live
and has flashbacks to his past failures
when trying to master the quirk
the translation says that deku
regretfully realizes and accepts
that he's not yet ready to use it all at
this time
which i think is referring to you know
the different multiple quirks i think
it's important to remember that deku
already knows what most of the quirks
he's going to get
are because all might gave him this book
that kind of detailed pretty much all
the quirks
except for these second and third users
the scene then shifts again
and this time it's a flashback to mirko
attacking shigaraki's container
at which point he was at 75 completion
we then see a random hero holding an
injured mirko
telling her to go to sleep according to
the translation though
mirko replies by saying you win if you
live
which again i think this is just her way
of saying that she needs to remain
conscious right now
but yeah sometimes it's hard to tell
what these uh rough translations
actually mean
regardless this is a major death flag
for mirko as the next panel cuts back to
shigaraki
who uses the two fingers on his left
hand to hold his damaged right arm in
place
he then crouches down to the ground and
yells out if you touch it it's over
he makes contact with the ground and
just a wave of decay springs into action
heading straight for the heroes however
in one of the most
iconic moments the series has ever seen
deku leaps into the sky
and uses black whip to pull everyone
into the air and avoid the destruction
this includes endeavour rock clock
bakago shoto literally everyone
and he finally for the first time
activates his
third quirk which is called float this
previously belonged to nana shimura who
was the seventh user of one for all
and it's the perfect counter to
shigaraki's decay quirk because
it allows him to float in the air like
it says rock clock is super confused at
this moment
and he's like floating like what is
going on i can empathize
with him a lot because if i didn't know
about one for all i'd be pretty damn
confused myself as to how this one kid
uses all these vastly different powers
like what does it look like he has a
black whip quirk he has some sort of
superpower quirk and now he's floating
in the air like
yeah that's pretty crazy we then see
gran torino who is somehow still
breathing
and he smiles fondly whilst remembering
his time
flying next to nana shimura back in the
day deku then pulls up in front of
shigaraki
and uses his new power to float in the
air and says
in the air i will stop you i'll do
everything i can
and with that the chapter ends and what
an ending it was
while this is the first time we've seen
deku use float i do wonder if it's the
very first time he's actually used it i
mean oh my did say a while ago that
float would be the next quirk deku
unlocks so maybe he has some experience
with it that we've just not seen
um it would definitely be a bonus you
know coming up against shigeraki
it would be good to have a little bit of
experience to know what you're doing
anyway there is no new chapter next week
uh the manga is on hiatus
for one week only so in two weeks we
will get chapter 284
and remember to smash that subscribe
button if you haven't already
and until the next one peace out